ah well so we have diagnostic
information here but we can also get a
3d view of what the hololens actually
see so this is the point cloud and or
rather mesh that it's creating in real
time as you can see that the room was
standing in there's the table that's a
point of view of the hololens in real
time this person view there is a bit of
a delay the hololens does not need a
cable of any sort it's all on board this
has just given preview otherwise is
really laggy over Wi-Fi when similar
service it was I love this so can you be
sinkers it might because you're actually
a dynamic mesh you might not be tracking
you are you actually showing up
something that maybe let's see if I
update it and give it that's okay yep
and that is enough information for the
hololens say right there's some sort of
object i'll see my camera it works up
we'll get lots of boxes on the table all
right yeah
to ever follow this okay and I'll just
tell the top plate the mesh well so this
is basically a depth map of me pretty
much yeah well from this angle if only I
could walk around other words I'm seeing
some blinking red lights on you that is
the depth camera ray that's on the top
of the hololens very similar to a Kinect
so the exact cocktail of sensors is not
not very well known
so keep American sort of just about
theorized but it feels a bit like I'm
walking to the future
indeed it is of all the various head
mounts we have this one is probably the
more star trekky of the lot just like
the Kinect all the tango and all those
devices what is doing is reading the
environment around it which is different
from what say normal optical AR does and
by creating a meshes understand the
environment around it and we can start
placing content there so as you can see
that's the example of the met of what
it's seeing the mesh it's creating in
real time because the realization that
all the time it's reading the
environment all the time and now this is
a view exactly what I see so I can
populate the world around me with any
virtual contact I want so this is the
menu basically you should be able to see
it there we are so that is a hologram in
space let's go place some other stuff
for example my settings I can either
place it in space just leave it there or
I can go find a nice flat surface like
say the side of this printer and place
it and that is now locked there that's
where it belongs so that is now normal
Windows 10 menu many of you will
probably have seen it before
there we are all we can start placing
other stuff in let's place a it's a
theme we put around three lines for
these demos usually so that is now
locked on to the table
it won't hover it won't move it is there
now the key thing here unlike most of
the other AR solutions we have seen is
seeing as these sensors have an
understanding of depth they can deal
with the occlusion problem so the
occlusion problem is where the NEA our
solution doesn't exactly know what it's
looking at now so and in which case it
draws the digital content above
everything so if you've used any AR a
mobile phone-based AR with a marker you
have probably tried putting your hand in
front of the marker see if it if it
occludes the virtual content oh you know
what it tries to go pick stuff up
normally the with marker base they are
that simply won't work all it can really
do is tie content to that marker but in
this case it does have a sense of depth
so it can effectively read your hand and
stop drawing content over it so if I put
my hand over the cat right you can see
now it is not working because I wasn't
triggered from my hand just yet but it
will eventually catch on
behind his laptop with the cat
disappeared and laugh it should assuming
the the device has actually read the
laptop let's have a girl that is stuck
this is speaking of happen quite often
all I know that it's only for the
preview really okay basically because
we're looking at on the left ended it's
a good debug view as far as my
experience goes on the hololens
everything is smooth open there we are
so let's have a look sadly we don't have
a lot of occlusions here no my laptop
doesn't seem to want to hide it the
problem with the room here is there's
not a lot of stuff to hide behind so
let's try something else if I was to
take a another hologram and place it
behind something like sit on the floor
over here alright there we are I can see
the dog and now tables in the way can't
see it yep so this is a case where the
geometry has been correctly read so the
hololens is sure that that is a static
feature in my environment so it now has
built geometry as we saw before x we can
switch back to the previous view there
we are so this is the geometry that it
is using for the occlusion yes exactly
so previously the cat could not be
hidden behind the laptop because as you
can see the laptop showing up as a short
mesh if I had kept moving it probably
would have hidden it the table though is
a nice solid object it's got that and
the dog is hiding behind the table so I
can see the hologram from here you
probably cannot on the screen now
because we're seeing the preview but as
I move and behind the table its hidden
this is not systematically scan the
entire room we got all the geometry
randomly so only you can try that with
that yes yes seeing as this is an
entirely onboard process so unlike say
all the virtual reality hazards we've
seen this is not required this little
computer it's basically a mobile phone
strapped to my face just like the tango
there is continuously trade-off between
speed and performance so if you want to
maintain the experience that everything
is
moves say at about thirty frames per
second for all the content I'm seeing
it's going to start cutting corners and
it also goes down to the basically that
give abilities of the sensors how much
granularity can they pick up how much
details so you'll see that they kind of
tend to cut corners they will ignore
clutter on the tables they're not very
good with the see-through surfaces so
for example the glass walls over here as
you can see they will simply not
register because it all comes down to
computer vision in this case flop
computer vision under sensors just like
we have seen with other AR stuff when
it's through some sort of glass case or
what-have-you the cameras actually see
the reflections but unlike our brains
they do not know to discard them
so now we know what to do with them the
depth sensors there in this case at she
straight through them so that is both a
good thing and a bad thing depending on
your and how you want to apply it so I
could place a hologram there but it
wouldn't necessarily see it as a wall so
let's see what we can do of course it's
not all just placing Holograms around
right off the bat it's the idea that you
can use the environment around you as
you're well computing environments so
you can just transplant your everyday
desktop use into the environment so I
can place a word file over there I can
put my browser on my silly make it a
massive screen obviously there are a lot
of uses in entertainment so the games on
this thing are pretty good if they will
use the environment you can use the
physics of your the environment around
you so you can have a ball bounce on the
table bounce on the floor people have
try this kind of just your face and
moving around kind of interface is
completely before it doesn't ever really
seem to say stop people are quite
comfortable the keyboard of a mouse or
trackpad indeed really this is probably
one of the first examples where I've
seen people just click with it so it
doesn't got really lot to gestures it
recognizes the click and the menu but
that is enough it is it is enough for
you to be able to do basic interactions
such as drag stuff around scroll around
select things in a way you normally
might you know pointing at something is
a norm
interaction and translates quite well
and if the it'll is a reliability factor
so one of the reasons these things don't
catch on is because they usually don't
work they have you know you're sitting
there tapping things this one is just
registering and working quite well the
two gestures for example the the bloom I
believe it's called just works reliably
every time same as the other main
interaction which is the click so I'm
not well there we go every time I click
we get an update of the mesh you can see
how it's reading the mesh their
environment around it or if I want to
get rid of Windows just Punk out what I
want and remove there we do have a bit
of a problem yes I can select things and
there are two gestures that work very
reliably but what we're missing is a
cursor yes I do have a cursor in the
middle of like a like a crosshair in the
middle of my view but that means I'm
relying on the direction of my head in
order to basically look at something
center in the middle of my screen and
then select it this is a good and bad
thing there are various interaction
methods to do this maybe I could point
at something but you see that pointing
is actually not one of the most accurate
things in the world it we have some
other studies with other interfaces
where you can see that people think
they're pointing at something but really
the pointing with Iran the pointing with
a wrist point with the finger so getting
a system that understands the intent of
the user is pretty difficult but gaez is
pretty solid we have a crosshair we aim
at what we want we select it listen to
preview here which is a camera on the
front of the device machine if you all
feel the feel a lot wiser than that can
you see more stuff if you're looking at
that cat what can you see at the size of
your that is a very good question it's
actually one of the things that well
surprises most people when they put this
on the field of view is actually flat
narrow unlike pretty much every headset
exists right now this is to help the
heads-up display meaning it's not like
the Google glasses where I'd have my
real vision and then a second window up
in the corner give me a version of the
real world
this is directly adding content to my
normal vision the problem is the area
that it has to add this content is
really very narrow
it's the equivalent of a 15-inch screen
at normal distance so really my field of
view of augmented content and this
sounds bad but it's not that bad is
really just this angle over here he's
real nervous yes yes I can see the gnome
it's all perfectly clear so I can see
the cat now it's in the center of my
vision but if I move my head ever so
slightly at this point the cat is
outside my augmented field of view it is
quite narrow but this is a technology
limitation that - finding is has already
been overcome it sir it's again a
trade-off between cost and performance
these are developer kits after all so
they're really pretty pricey if they
were to have a proper field of view
probably the weight and power
requirements would have made them quite
unwieldy at a time you know the most
works very well Cortana so we shall get
on the camera and skip this were like
sure so we have to look out through one
of the eyes I guess oh yeah look I say
yep I said content oh you know yeah and
okay okay so because I guess that yeah
aim one at the camp okay and then we
know there's content
mmm keeping a close eye on the others
Oh hot I'll get rid of them we move
forward there you go right it's quite
interesting to see that Lauren is now
that on the caption Aaronson and then
what click or something yep so whenever
you can interact with something the dot
will turn into a circle ah indeed and
also when it sees your fingers and it
says okay you're ready to click same
thing